oscar pistorius arrives at court for the
third day of examination as a witness
the defense have used the first two days
of questioning to portray the athlete as
scared and vulnerable when he shot reeva
Steenkamp the prosecutor quickly set
about trying to destroy that image
through aggressive questioning you made
a mistake that's correct you kill the
person that's what it is isn't it I made
a mistake you killed leave us can't come
that's what you did I made a mistake
quality you you're repeating at three
times what was your mistake I'm stuck
because that I took leave this life you
killed her you shot and killed it work
you take responsibility for that I took
my lady that's how you say yes I killed
I shot and killed reeva Steenkamp I took
my lady okay the judge then permitted
the prosecution to show video footage of
Pistorius firing guns overruling
objections that it was inadmissible
character evidence and amounted to
illegal ambush of the defense the
athlete broke down when Gerry nel then
asked him to view a photograph of
steenkamp's fatal head wound take
responsibility for what you've done mr.
Pistorius I've taken responsibility but
I will not look at a picture where I'm
so minted but what I saw and felt that
not as a pict river up my fingers
touched ahead I remember I don't have to
look at a picture I was there Pistorius
faces possible life imprisonment if
convicted of premeditated murder